question the violence in New York City
it's leading to questions about the
NYPD's response especially the use of
force by officers so joining us now is
New York City Police Commissioner Dermot
Shay Commissioner Shane good morning I
want to get right to that video we just
saw two New York City police cruisers
accelerating into protesters I know you
said you you employ a light touch that
certainly they look like a light touch
yeah yeah let's look at the context for
a second in a very volatile situation
over a series of days we've had numerous
encounters well organized crowds not not
peaceful protests organized crowds are
intentionally trying to ambush police
officers in cars it's not being widely
reported it's a fact it's a fact we've
had officers try to be burned alive in
course we have officers trying to be
blocked in with roadblocks and then
surrounded and attacked and pulled out
of course while they're in there that's
what the officers have been dealing with
over the course of three or four days
unfortunate but that is a reality so
that's the the backdrop of this coil the
officers are on patrol and a very
volatile situation getting a call for
assistance which they're trying to go to
and they're immediately penned in you
see the crowd surged around them you see
the barricades being placed and held
there this is not happenstance this is
intentional it's criminal activity you
see somebody throw a bag and the report
is a bag and trying to light a car the
police car on fire onto the roof of the
car so that's the reports I would ask
you you are those officers what would
you do you can't go backwards
you can't go forwards they're not
letting you you're trying to get out of
there you've had officers try to be
killed within the last hours of that
incident taking place what would usually
shake Commissioner say that is a good
question I think what people will have
to decide is whether those officers
could have backed up which brings me to
the subject of de-escalation we've seen
some of your officers taken knee walk in
solidarity with protesters could that be
part of a broader plan to lower the
temperature here in the city and
nationwide
yeah and that's a great question and
I've seen reports of a tenacious
wine it's a beautiful thing it's
happening here again it's not always
reported but we stand in solidarity with
people that tarnish the law enforcement
shield and profession I think yeah I
think it's a healthy thing it's clearly
not enough here that people came out
immediately and denounced what was on
that video
people want accountability but I think
we all know it's not just about that
incident it's a greater issue that
really transcends New York City
certainly New York City is a part of it
in the frustration but but that's I
think you hit it on the head that it's
together we're a minority majority
department but it shouldn't be about
ethnicity here everyone is everyone are
human beings and seeing each other and
hearing each other and coming from
individual places but we should stand
together and we should say what's right
yeah and we are walking with protesters
we are showing solidarity with them and
we just urge everyone peaceful protests
let's enact change let's hold everyone
whether it's law enforcement some
punishment officials accountable so
commissioner you mentioned the the
national problem it's bigger than this
one incident it's bigger than the death
of George Floyd so let me put it to you
plainly why do black men continue to die
in this country at the hands of police
at a much greater rate than white men or
Latino men and I wish I had the answer
for that and I think it's a broader
question but I think it's someone agrees
ISM is aware what I call it systemic
racism I'm sorry I would call it
something that we all have to
acknowledge I think we do I saw
something that we all would have to work
together to fix and I don't think it's
just about law enforcement I think it
speaks to I a long history in this
country I think it speaks to pervasive
problems in this country when you think
about disproportionate whether it's
income or incarceration rates that go
well beyond one Police Department or a
law enforcement in particular and I
think it's something that all of us are
going to have to continue to work
towards so that everyone
to figure up that equal shop we quality
yeah
commissioner Dermot che thank you very
much the question is gonna be what is
that something and if we can't name it
how do we fix it I appreciate your time
this morning and good luck to you and
your officers in the days ahead
thank you very much